Now let's see a two-way set associative cache in action.
We will assume a 5-bit address space with a 2 byte
cache length. Notice that I've added a valid bit to
our cache here, so that we can tell whether data has
ever been loaded up to a line in the cache.
Uninitialized caches are called coal. Let's say that 0 is the
first address. In most systems that's not allowed, but it's fine
for our example. The second bit here tells us the index
for the cache. So we'll need to put this
in the 0 set somewhere. We put it in here,
flipping the recently used item to say 1, because
that would be our preferred place to write the next
cache line with index 0. Maybe after this, I
have an address that looks like this one. The index
here is 1, so we want to put it in this
group, and again I'll put it in the first line,
setting the valid bit, writing the data, and marking
the least recently used bit. Our next address has
index 0, so it gets written there. Notice that
I chose this slot because the LRU had been one,
and I flipped it back to zero because this
is now the least recently used item in this
part of the cache. Next we have an address
with index 1. We checked the tag and we see
that it's a hit. Oh my goodness. Notice that this address is a hit, even
though we didn't read the exact same address
before. But we did read an address belonging
to the same cache block. Next, we have
another address with index 0. So, he comes
in here and evicting one of the previous
entries. This one, because of the LRU bit.